carl sagan he has written so many
popular science books
and brought us the original cosmos
series which has inspired so many people
to dream about space the surface
of the earth is the shore of the cosmic
ocean
on this shore we've learned most of what
we know
recently we've waded a little way up
maybe
ankle deep and the water seems inviting
some part of our being knows this is
where we came from
we long to return and we can
because the cosmos is also within us
we're made of star stuff
we are a way for the cosmos to know
itself
sagan was also an accomplished
researcher
and is one of the most highly cited
planetary scientists
so i wanted to take a look today at
where that all started
by taking a look at his phd thesis
now sagan went to the university of
chicago
and he completed his phd in 1960
when he was age 25. the title
is physical studies of planets and his
supervisor
was gerard kuiper of whom the kuiper
belt is named after
on the cover page here we can see the
name carl sagan
and his signature the thesis is
in four parts part one
indigenous organic matter on the moon
part two biological contamination of the
moon
part three the radiation balance venus
and part 4 production of organic
molecules
and planetary atmospheres these topics
reflect his interest in astrobiology
he was known for thinking a lot about
life in the cosmos
and he was a big promoter of seti the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
there is some chance that in the next
few decades we will get a
signal from some spectacularly distant
spectacularly exotic civilization and
everything on earth will as a
consequence change
if there's a plausible argument that
there isn't anybody out there
bearing in mind that we can be wrong we
ought to keep looking
because the question is of the most
supreme
importance it calibrates our place in
the universe
it tells us who we are and so
it is worthwhile trying to find other
civilizations
i would say no matter what part one
starts
off by saying that for some time after
its formation
the moon possessed an atmosphere
composed of
methane ammonia water vapor and hydrogen
and says the effect of solar uv
light on an atmosphere is that organic
molecules of fair complexity
are produced and the purpose of this
present paper
is to estimate the quantity of organic
matter
which formed in the primitive lunar
atmosphere
diffused to the surface and survived to
the present day
this was written 10 years before the
apollo astronauts would land on the moon
and sagan is pretty interested in the
idea of finding organic molecules there
organic molecules i guess are of special
interest
since they are precursors to life
or are used a lot in biology
you may have heard that the moon has
such a weak atmosphere now that it could
be considered to have no atmosphere
or actually be considered a pretty good
vacuum
but sagan is referencing material that
says that that wasn't always the case
the moon's atmosphere requires
replenishment from the interior of the
moon
and gradually escapes so the moon's
atmosphere might once have been
very thick before most of it has been
lost to space
sagan first works out a surface density
of synthesized material
so this would be a covering of these
organic molecules
and it's more common to hear of uv light
breaking down molecules
than helping to build them but remember
that sunlight is thought to be
an essential part of the equation for
how we got
life in the first place that the effect
of
uv radiation on bonds and molecules
helps them break down but also builds
into longer chains
the effect of heat and uv light on the
molecules
is remarkable he says a large fraction
of the molecules partake in organic
synthesis
of a higher order of complexity
polypeptides arise from amino acids
hydrocarbon diamonds form long chain
polymers
and in general very complex organic
molecules are constructed
this continued radiation and high
temperatures
would eventually destroy these molecules
but during this time
there were a lot of meteors hitting the
moon and a lot of this
meteorite material falling into the
lunar atmosphere
so sagan says the moon's surface must
have received a dust cover
probably composed primarily of silicates
and ices
the organic molecules would then be
covered
by a protective layer insulating them
from the extremes of temperature
and absorbing the radiation so he says
that provided no large-scale destructive
events
we may anticipate the presence of
complex
organic matter beneath the moon's dust
layer
this would only apply to regions that
have had no extensive lava flows
the southern highland appears to be such
a region
as does much of the far side of the moon
and he finishes this first section of
the thesis by saying that
to figure out much more what we'll need
is a
sample of lunar material from below the
surface
scientists have since found some of
these molecules
in samples that we took from the moon
and although we haven't found
any life there we have found some of the
essential ingredients
part two is about the biological
contamination of the moon
sagan is expecting that soon humans will
start landing on the moon
and he expresses concern that
terrestrial microorganisms
meaning from earth and organic matter
deposited with the packages may obscure
detection of
or interact with possible organisms or
organic matter indigenous to the moon
such biological contamination of the
moon
would represent an unparalleled
scientific disaster
and because of it scientific
opportunities lost on the moon
may not be recoupable elsewhere
he lists four classes of possible
lunar biological contamination and i
haven't found reference to these words
anywhere outside this thesis
so maybe they are words of his own
invention
but the first one is bio mixi which is
that the moon may contain
no indigenous living organisms and may
be
incapable of supporting terrestrial
organisms
however there may be relics of primitive
indigenous organisms
deposited on or beneath the surface
and a vehicle impacting the moon may
distribute its contents
over the surface such that further
investigations
might be unable to distinguish between
the primitive indigenous organisms
and ones that came along from earth this
is pretty similar to the second type
listed as sapro-mixie and then we have
the third type
phagomixie which is that the moon may
contain
no indigenous living organisms but may
be capable of supporting
some terrestrial organisms this would
require subsurface organic matter
moisture and heat sources the
possibility then exists that
deposited microorganisms from earth in
the absence of
any competitors or predators will
multiply
at a geometric rate limited only by
the availability of water and
metabolites
this would give a biological explosion
and you can probably see that this
wouldn't be
very helpful for trying to study the
history of the moon
and the fourth type of contamination is
eco
mixy that the moon itself may contain
indigenous living organisms that is that
there may be life
on the moon there is then the
possibility that deposited
microorganisms from earth
by competition with or parotism upon
even one species of lung organism will
disrupt the ecology
completely so these are kind of all the
ways we could screw things up on the
moon
by accidentally depositing some of our
own biology
and doing a bit of math and looking at a
few of the numbers
including the survival law which would
tell how long the organisms from earth
could even survive if they were
accidentally left on the moon
sagan comes up with a few conclusions
about
how likely each of these possibilities
are
he finds that most microorganisms would
be killed by the uv radiation
within a few hours but if any make their
way
into a lunar crevasse or are otherwise
shielded from the radiation
then they might survive for quite some
time
and while the possibilities may be low
of
life spreading or surviving or even
getting there in the first place
sagan finds that all of those types of
contamination
cannot be excluded and are not
negligible
and i suppose the whole paper is a
little bit of a warning to make sure
that when spacecraft
leave earth on their way to the moon
that we sterilize them really thoroughly
the third part of the thesis the
radiation balance of venus
is the longest section and probably
contains the most
notable work sagan was trying to explain
a recent microwave observation of venus
that gave its surface temperature as
being near
600 kelvin previously scientists had
taken what they thought they knew about
the surface of venus
and used that to try and work out a
projected temperature
but sagan worked backwards he took this
temperature measurement and tried to
figure out how it came about
it was certainly higher than the
expected temperature of such a planet
which is quoted here as being no more
than 350 degrees kelvin
and what sagan says here is that it is
clear that a surface temperature of
600 kelvin demands a very
efficient greenhouse effect so his
calculations found that essentially a
runaway
greenhouse effect was able to explain
this very high temperature
this effect would occur when there are a
lot of greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere
trapping radiation from the sun and
heating up the planet
carbon dioxide and water vapor are both
greenhouse gases and sagan proposes that
it is water excess water in the
atmosphere that could explain the
greenhouse effect
on venus but later missions to venus
actually found that there was very
little water in the atmosphere
and instead it was almost entirely
carbon dioxide
the radiation balance of a planet is a
very delicate
thing and it seems likely that venus
wasn't always
so hot and unwelcoming it might have
been much more livable like earth
but it is closer to the sun and hotter
and drier than earth
and the carbon compounds might have
evaporated
rather than remaining in the rocks
leading to its greenhouse effect to
essentially run away
leading to a vicious cycle where the
planet just gets hotter and hotter
sagan discusses what might have happened
if the earth had been placed in the
orbit of venus
in its primitive times and essentially
its
fate is much the same the oceans would
boil
the carbon dioxide abundance would go up
and earth wouldn't be the home
that we know it to be all of this
research into what
caused the fate of venus and thinking
about what might happen to earth in
different circumstances
probably led carl sagan to be quite
worried about things like global warming
and passionate about trying to
communicate what was going on
now no one has proposed that the trouble
with venus is that there once was
venusians who drove fuel and efficient
cars
but our nearest neighbor nevertheless is
a stark warning
on the possible fate of an earth-like
world
the last section of the thesis is this
one here
which is actually an experimental
project sagan is again
talking about how organic molecules are
produced
when energy is supplied to an atmosphere
of methane ammonia water and hydrogen
he uses spectroscopy to find the spectra
of some of these known end products
and list the features that he finds in
this table
what he then does is compares this
laboratory spectra
to spectra taken with a telescope but
looking at some of the jovian planets
including jupiter and saturn from his
observations he thinks that
it's possible that there is hydrogen
cyanide
present in the atmosphere of jupiter
however this was only a preliminary
report
and so he's not able to really
conclusively say these things
but has set up this field of science for
some further investigation
and that is a look at carl sagan's
thesis which would set him
up for a very successful career further
tackling all of these questions
thinking about the atmospheres of
planets and the likelihood of finding
life there
thanks for watching and thanks as always
to my patreon supporters
who make these videos possible a special
shout out to today's patreon cats of the
day
minerva and isis i hope to see you next
[Music]
time
you